queen bee and jay-z's rare night out and
justin bieber hops back on the apology
train is it two lane that you know what
I'm not even going to go there hey guys
this is the daily Denny and just 15 days
after giving birth to the twins
mama Beyonce is glowing as she stepped
out for a kid-free night with the hubs
the power couple was spotted enjoying a
romantic dinner day at sushi park in LA
on Wednesday by the way sushi park
sounds magical and I want to go to there
I want to go to there now how do I know
it was romantic well an eye witness
tells et jay-z caressed his wife's back
as they stared at the moon but what I
really want to talk about is Beyonce's
out there looking like a wax figure
except Beyonce's actual wax figure is a
joke I can't even look at that thing but
he is in good company when it comes to
some wack looking wax figures New
England Patriots stars sometimes model
Tom Brady was just memorialized in wax
a Boston wax museum unveiled what can
only be described as an attempt at
capturing the essence of the quarterback
naturally it didn't exactly receive a
hero's welcome on Twitter I mean we'll
get it but shout out to Josh Billington
on Twitter for putting it into
perspective at least it's not courtroom
sketch Tom Brady even so the museum set
out a response to the backlash asking
Tom to come in for is sitting to make it
perfect but can we just end the wax
figure move it you guys agree with me or
not
holler at me in the comments right now
you know today is also Tom's 40th
birthday
his wife Giselle Bundchen Instagram this
more fitting tribute to him writing over
10 years ago I fell in love with you
because of your beautiful and sensitive
heart I love the sweetness in your
essence happy birthday my love making 40
feel like 20 well damn
Tom Giselle I'm throwing up a big 9 on
the John and Chrissy scale for ya he's
devastatingly beautiful couple
all right how's this for a sweet tribute
though late Linkin Park frontman Chester
Bennington is being remembered with a
beautiful new mural in Lhasa
Angeles the 20-foot painting was just
completed by artist Jonas never danced
in LA can see the massive mural from the
101 freeway just behind music-themed
pizza spot rock and pies
it features Chester shirtless and
smiling the artist told variety he
thought that image would be better than
having him up there screaming he also
says he offered to paint the mural for
free because it was the right thing to
do now there have been some amazing
tributes to Chester since his passing
including this one from Coldplay the
band opened the first show of their
North American tour with this stripped
down cover of Linkin Park's crawling
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful chills right meanwhile after a
rough week Justin Bieber is on the mend
with a new purpose in life leaves got
personal in a lengthy new Instagram post
writing I let my broken relationships
dictate the way I acted toward people
and the way I treated them
I let bitterness jealousy and fear run
my life the 23 year old caught some flak
for his abrupt tour cancellation he
explained me taking this time right now
is me saying I want to be sustainable so
that I can be the man I want to be the
husband I eventually want to be and the
father I want to be this break seems to
be doing JB some good plus remember that
paparazzo Justin accidentally struck
last week well et has learned Justin
will not be charged and police
determined it was the photographer who
was at fault so things are looking up
for you beads you know who else is on
the healing path Justin's ex Selena
Gomez she cancelled her world tour last
October and details her treatment to
focus on mental health in September's
InStyle magazine Selena spent 90 days
completely off the grid and says she was
scared but it was amazing and she also
gave gushy talking openly about how
fulfilling her relationship with the
weekend is saying quote you want someone
at your life not complete you I'm lucky
because he's more of a bestfriend than
anything else well I'm single so you
guys are my best friends
so BFFs thank you for watching like
comment share subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel because there's so much
fun there and of course check out all
these stories and so much more
over at ET online.com i'ma shimmy my way
out of here good bye you guys see you
tomorrow